[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 23 of
GameSpot after dark we are back from the
holidays we actually I guess did have an
episode last week but that we recorded
that a couple weeks ago so we are back
for the first episode of 2020 my name is
Jake I'm your host and I'm here with
Peter Brown hello tomorrow who's saying
hello and Kelly plaguey hey Lucy is back
but she is unfortunately sick so she's
sitting out this episode but that's okay
we got quite the episode planned today
we're gonna go over what we've been
playing we're gonna get into some of the
topics and news of the week which
include that Playstation 5 logo bang
yeah I'm excited hear all your thoughts
oh yeah
apparently the entirety of Final Fantasy
seven links apart from the game itself
maybe we'll touch on that a little bit
and then finally we're gonna wrap up the
show with listener questions but before
we do that I do want to give an update
on the discord server we talked about
that briefly last week or a couple weeks
ago still in progress be patient it'll
be there soon but to everyone who's
emailed us so far thank you so much and
we'll have that good to go soon or just
waiting for a few more things but anyway
let's get into it
Peter Brown hi how was your break what
you do yeah it was a very eventful I
spent three weeks abroad two in Japan
one in Hong Kong and Japan I got engaged
we play video games yeah I proposed to
my girlfriend and she said she said no
at first because she didn't know what I
was doing we were in this well we were
so she didn't know I was gonna have the
ring even though we've been planning to
get it did the projection for shipping
was way off anyways we were in this like
art installation thing we only had like
one minute in this room and she was like
let's take a selfie and I was like no
wait let's do something first I started
to get down on my knee I just think that
she didn't know what I was doing or I
was asking her to do something weird she
goes no it was like who you marry me yes
sure what okay anyway so yeah I got
engaged it's a selfie we did I think I
put it on social media but it wasn't
from inside that thing
and it's all blur man but after that I
spent a lot of time eating and shopping
for a Sega Saturn games yeah and then I
went to Hong Kong which is eventful have
you been to Hong Kong before a couple
times yeah and I know some people there
and so it's always great to see them and
hang out with them but the protests
everything you're seeing in the news
like it's all anyone can talk about for
good reason it's all over the place it
was kind of a trip just to you know see
dozens of cops in riot gear just be just
in case you know just hanging out just
in case something pops off it was always
you know like oh that place we were at
earlier today okay that's where the
riots are right now that kind of thing
it's happening so it's a city with a lot
of problems and that just really
elevated I think it's it's the biggest
challenges that its citizens are facing
so after that came home and now I'm back
at work and it's great to see all you
get any cool Sega Saturn games yeah I
think I bought close to 20 games so
there's a long but I was shopping for a
lot of small stuff it's a lot of the
basics I've ignored over the years but I
picked up some games that wouldn't
usually think of like alien trilogy on
Sega Saturn it's a system that is often
critiqued for not being great at 3d
gaming relative to something like
PlayStation but first person shooters
actually have a lot of interesting
stories on there and a lot of them came
from a studio called lobotomy software
but alien trilogy is different and is
just interesting on its own so yeah that
was sort of unexpected by mmm-hmm
but it wasn't too expensive so well the
one did you get one more one more one
coolest one Shh oh I got these I got two
sanshiro minigame collection you guys
all know I got this yeah he's a famous
Japanese actor who during the sega
saturn's lifespan played like a karate
master who would always like find people
in situations who were liking to be sad
or like failing to do something and help
them train through Sega Saturn games and
he's very serious like but really iconic
character because of his attitude he's
really funny
there's a collection of mini-games on
Saturn where you're just doing a lot of
that outlandish training stuff from the
commercials so I actually never
about buying that game I saw once in
this trip and I was like oh maybe and I
passed it up and I was like god damn it
and I missed it in Japan found it again
at Hong Kong so I'd then I picked it up
I was like this is fate telling me
something nothing you know yeah but when
I was there I also saw that virtual on
twin sticks which do you anyone know
what those I know the virtual on but no
the 26 so virtual line is normally paid
you know it's like tank controls right
so you have two sticks and like you do
this to turn you strafe by moving both
left and right and they're like handheld
flight yokes basically those controllers
go for like 90 bucks on eBay pretty
regularly but I saw them on sale in
Japan for like 22 big to bring back but
through a proxy service I bought them on
yahoo auctions thinking they would be
cheap there as well like 15 bucks and
virtual on is a fun game and I've never
actually played it using the controller
it was designed for us I'm really
excited about that yeah I remember
playing it and being like I don't
understand I think you need those sticks
to really get that man yeah I gotta put
my glasses back on I cannot see y'all
what kind of game is it yeah it is a
it's like an arena mech combat game okay
yeah I mean pretty it's not terribly
ambitious but it was like one of the
first of its kind and has that great
kind of like mid-90s Sega like attitude
to it and it's an iconic Sega Saturn
game as well yeah good yeah oh yeah it's
a great vacation yeah it was pretty good
that sounds so leaden no variety there
oh yeah there's way more but I don't
want to bore people
you guys I did nothing
play a lot of blood-borne not even that
I don't really on here it says you
played Batman Arkham origins
oh I went back to London for three weeks
and the next day I woke up and I was
like did I just dream that I moved to
San Francisco like genuinely I was like
did I dream that and then like snapped
out I was negotiating now I'm back if
all like I hadn't been gone at all and I
was I had like a list of stuff that ways
to play and do and things I wanted to
watch and then I don't know what
happened but I did
currently none of it like just sat
around and wasted the days away I played
like a couple games here and there like
Batman Arkham origins is the only one
that I played like started it and then
finished it and then break and it was
within the space of like two days so
I've been playing the I always play the
Arkham series yearly almost so and
origins is always lost and it's a
Christmas game is set you're in
Christmas so it makes perfect sense to
put it during that era I don't like a
lot of them set during Christmas like
the day before Christmas know I don't
know they thought there was one that was
like the night before Christmas
Malka margins is Christmas yeah yeah
yeah like a long of it a lot of the the
actual novelizations are all graphic
novels a lot of stories around the
Christmas period so that's why is
there's like a good close relationship
between Batman and Christmas stories so
origins the one I played I played a city
night and asylum earlier this year and
origins is like it holds up really
really well I think that's like it gets
a lot of stick because like night when
it came out it had some issues or like
bugs and stuff like that but it's a
fantastic game it's got some amazing
boss fights in it that's something I
haven't played oh you should play it's
so good I was hoping there'd be like a
decent mod community for it um like
updated visuals and textures and stuff
but now people just making stupid Batman
cost you what's the best boss fight you
say there are a lot of good ones so I
really like the Deathstroke one it's
really it does it's very like intense
and it's very cute EEE focused but it's
it feels really fluid and kind of like
the combat system it really like
flourishes in that moment because it
requires you to not just punch and
counter but it's like use your gadgets
because there's moments where you'll be
like here we use his gadgets to launch a
like an explosive barrel towards you and
you've got to use your Batarang to kind
of take it out and/or grapple it away
and that kind of stuff but just looks
really nice and it feels very cinematic
there are a few boss battles that aren't
as good like the Firefly one towards the
end is kind of annoying but like
generally they're solid boss fights
there's
one with I think his Copperhead who kind
of like poisons you and then you're
fighting loads of versions of her but
it's like maybe thirty of her on screen
but only the one is the one that you can
actually do damage to and she's like
vanishing into the background smoke and
coming back and there's lucky you're
kind of losing your mind at the same
time they do the Mad Hatter one as well
which is in the Scarecrow moments from
the other games where it's like an
illusion they do even Mad Hatter and
it's kind of like this insane skewed
version of like Alice in Wonderland
because obviously he's obsessed with
that story and you go into that world
and do like a platforming segment
through this incredibly skewed fever
dream version of Alice in Wonderland
that's super strong nothing on perhaps
on the level of like mr. freeze in
Arkham City but still each one feels
distinct which is it says a lot because
a lot of the characters that they use
are kind of like almost see and beat
here characters it's not like you know
you do have Joker in there in some
capacity but a lot of the fights that
you have are not super well-known
whether you have one against the
electrocutioner who is again like SCT
villain and it's amazing because you
fight him in the same arena as you fight
Deathstroke a little earlier but
electrocution is like a chump
so like he comes in and he's given it
the bigger and he's like I'm gonna you
know this because the whole story is
like black mask has put out a hit on
your head so like a bunch of assassins
are coming off to you all on this one
night and he's the first you fight and
you literally kill him in one punch his
name is kind of like like the electric
electrocution
absolutely treat like a chump in their
game which is exactly what it needs to
be it's like pitch perfect comedy which
is something that the rest of the games
don't really do that much they have fun
with it a bit so do you have a ranking
of those games yeah so mine is City
Asylum Knight origin
okay but they're all pretty good yeah I
think they're all essential games that I
think it's not controversial to say like
more it perhaps it is controversial I
think Knight is much better than people
remember it's another one like origins
that go wrapped up in the drama mm-hmm
because these PC port of it was like
atrocious yeah that kind of took over
the discussion around tonight which is a
shame because that was like a really
really interesting game how what they
did with the Joker in their game even
the stuff around the Batmobile I feel
like it got treated worse than it
actually was like they are moments where
it forces you to use the Batmobile and
use it in like a race car section and
that's where it kind of is it falls
about apart slightly but in the open
world the Batmobile is absolutely
amazing I think like it's critical to
that Batman fantasy where like you can
jump off like a high build and glide tap
l1 and you can see from a distance the
Batmobile coming and you just like trace
tracing its path to you and then as
you're touching down you just go
straight into it and carry on driving
like that's absolutely like when I first
did that I was like I was gonna cry I
was like this is phenomenal this is
amazing then launching yourself out of
it I have that one video or it's like a
car comes I put it on my YouTube or like
a car full of goons comes out comes past
and like they try to run you over and
they scream one of them screams you're
gonna be roadkill Batman and like it
misses you and then they come out at you
and like I fought them and like as I was
fighting the last one I hit the
Batmobile button and like did a punch
and then just walked away and as he was
stumbling back from the punch like the
hit of the punch the Batmobile came
skidding around the corner and any
anyone that gets too close to it it
shocks them and pushes them away and
like it came skidding around the corner
and hit him shocked him put him away and
I was like that was the coolest thing a
video game has ever done so like I think
Knight is way better and even narrative
Lee was the first one that pauldini
wasn't involved in and pulled in he's
like um he wrote the animated series
that everyone loves and is a well-known
like beloved Batman writer they didn't
have them so this was like internally
written by Sefton hill and a bunch of
the team
even still like it's a phenomenal story
I think it's a fantastic store in a
really interesting way to kind of end
that franchise so I think yeah night is
much better than people give it credit
for I hope that people have gone back to
his Sanderson like enjoyed it and given
it a second chance because I think it's
phenomenal but seasons my favorite III
enjoyed night when I played it I think
the only thing I really didn't like
about it at the time was that you had to
collect all the Joker stat everyone felt
this way we had to collect all the Joker
statues to get the real and dingy and I
started to do it and it was like there's
I don't know how I don't remember how
many there were but there were far too
many for me to do and I was like I like
this game but I'm just gonna Google the
real ending yes it's the Joker Riddler
so if that real ending is amazing though
yeah it is good love is good
so I played that start to finish now I'm
probably gonna at some point in next few
months
start all over so I'll start playing
asylum again I picked up blood stain
while I was in the UK as well because it
was going cheap my local August on the
switch I bought it for as I was hoping
what what's wrong with you I don't know
where it would be fine by then risky
purchase it was very risky like I went
online and like googled a few places and
I looked at a few articles and they were
like yeah it's fine it is not fine very
much its playable but a good Lord knows
loading times oh yeah because there's
the sections of the map where you have
to jump up putting the legs you'll fall
back down since you jump up loading
screen you get up no yeah unlike there's
something about and like I don't think
it's a hard game
I think it's an annoying game no I love
the enemies are designed in a way way
like the first time you count them
you're not sure what they're gonna do
like there's no way for you to like
observe and and kind of like react and
you know all like here's a giant there's
like friggin for example they don't have
like animations that they do independent
of you like no they all just stand there
they activate so there's the first one
you found like annoying was like there's
this giant Knight thing so like it's
just standing there I'm like maybe they
walk back and forth sure and I was like
giant Knight I've played every
Sylvania my my guess is raise the sword
and then like slightly down my man went
into a forward roll and like watch my
life just go I was like all right well
now I'm dead and like the last save
point was pretty far away the loading
screen is well long so every time I play
that game I have maybe like a 15 minute
session until I die and I'm like a
cotton bud icon I can't be asked like
its I can't on another platform I bet
you it's fine but I still find the
element like the enemy design is kind of
annoying it's just like they've got
every archetype from Symphony of the
Night
sure just made it a bit more annoying
and like there's a lot of stuff that I
do like by like the shard system seems
like it's really interesting and then we
can come up with different combinations
and stuff but it's just like every time
I'm playing it and like flying against
stuff from size all all annoying like
you're kind of and it looks the switch
version is not the way to go but yeah
it's see we knew that already
I thought kick-started the game and I
paid in at the hundred dollar level
because I Symphony the Knights one of my
favorite games of all time and you know
when it came time to choose which
version of the game I was gonna get I
didn't know the switch version was gonna
suck there was no talk of it being
diminished that's the one I got I
ultimately ended up selling everything I
got from the Kickstarter version there's
bought it digitally on ps4 cuz what the
hell yeah I've got it on PC but I got it
through the epic game store so I'll
probably end up playing there I bought
the switch one cuz it was like cheap
enough that I was like if at this price
even if it's free like I'll just play it
for a few hours now get my fill of it
and and I'll be done with it and I'll
probably carry on playing it for a
little while longer because I've seen
enough people be like oh it's real good
you know the Giant Bomb guys love it mmm
so maybe I'll play it through for a
little bit longer and get my fill of in
and just forget about it whatever those
guys were talking yeah Dan Reicher likes
blood-stained okay guy works for the WWE
that should fake I I played a pretty
good amount of blood stain on PC and I I
enjoyed it but it didn't it didn't pull
me through for some reason I think my
favorite thing though
is the shard system like yeah I'm about
because you could do some wild because
you can do some pretty fun combinations
and interesting ways to get out of it
like I remember the portraits that just
fly around you that do those which I
learned yeah I know you walk in you see
one of those pictures and you're just
like who what excuse me and then I
started playing Rainbow six siege
mumbles welcome yeah
I'm still going to take about this
earlier the the kind of opera is in that
game clearly started off like the first
phase of our prayers are the most boring
in the character select screen for
Rainbow six siege is dude with helmet
this was before they pivoted to like
yeah now you look at and it's like I
think it's ellos got like she looks like
Lady Gaga or something like that
yeah like green yeah hey bond has got
like a like a art show Japanese Archer
outfit and they've gone like you can see
it's like military military overwatch
overwatch I'm playing on ps4 and I play
it with one of the guys i compare i GN
simon Carly who's like a good friend of
mine and like he's getting me into it so
every time I play like I have to be like
Simon who should I play and he's like
pick this character and he usually tells
me thinker or Leon talk to me about
finger magic he told me to pick those
characters because they're relatively
easy to use think has got the adrenaline
boost it helps a bunch of people out and
you know Leon's got that drone thing
which I mean let's play rook so easy to
play yeah cook is the just set it and
forget you just throw down your shield
shield
come get your armor so I started playing
that game and I'm like I like I have to
ask Simon like where should I barricade
and like I sound very yeah he's like
he's like being my guide for the game I
really really like it scratching like
the counter-strike itch that I've I've
had for a while now but it doesn't feel
great on the controller and that's what
I was talking to you earlier like I
you're even saying having trouble
hitting the drones and I can't imagine
trying to dip those drones with this fix
and I think even we talked about before
- I don't think there's much aim-assist
there so you're kind of left in the dark
to use the this clunky ish aiming PC
it's like night and day PC is is
fantastic that's definitely the way to
play it if you can can you like tilts
yeah I can use the I click the sticks
oh you click but you can only tilt while
you're aiming right yeah you can't you
have to be aiming down sights yeah you
see you don't have to you can just hit I
think oh you can without yeah you can
you can do that so whenever you load and
people are just doing this I do like
that because you can see sometimes in
the kill account where someone kills
someone else like with a tilt and it
looks ridiculous but that game is like
the the map knowledge you need to be
good at that game is wild it's it's not
only like you need to you know check
your corners and these lines of sight
it's like oh this wall can be blown up
at any any you know moment's notice and
there's a whole like different sight
line going on now I have 50 or so hours
in siege now and I am finally getting a
hang of where cameras are located I am i
I still don't there's still maps where I
forget where cameras are located I think
that's one of my favorite things about C
but also my least favorite things is
that I've played this game for I think
350 hours now and I still get confused
on certain maps and not necessarily
because I think they're bad but it's
just because the way things can change
from match to match there's so many
different variables that I'll end up
holding a room that I'm like I don't
know where this is in relation to what
else I'm trying to do and then all of a
sudden a wall will blow open and be like
okay now I can get to this room which no
I wouldn't be able to so it's very
valuable
I would say the amount of times I've run
into a room and fallen through a hole in
the floor just because I had no idea it
wasn't there a few minutes ago
and like it's always he's always
watching me as I do it and he would like
take a video of it and post it but yeah
I'm really looking for I think I want to
start playing on PC as well I do only on
PC patiently with us yeah I'm into it
yes
yeah siege crew if you're still confused
then I don't feel as bad going in
completely common newbie so yeah I mean
and it definitely helps having someone
who's familiar especially with all the
operators now because there are so many
different strategies and characters and
abilities but the nice thing about siege
is that at the end of the day all you
have to do is shoot people in the head
yeah and that kills them so it's like
basically all your abilities are just
making certain things easier but it when
it comes down to it like it is just a
shooter yeah you don't need to worry
about your role it's like the time to
kill is so low like it's just one two
shots we also play casual to see Matt
Padgett in his unfiltered element I mean
that's the primary reason oh yeah that
community though the siege community
it's crazy awful good grief
what is going on in there especially on
PC they have had the crackdown some oh
you doing it yep do it into the mic if
you're listening Peter just opened his
beer and oh no it's fine foamy yeah the
the whole like friendly fire system
it's wild like people are the amount of
times I've loaded into a game and the
like T enemy or enemy teams or even
people on my team have been like killing
each other immediately and you're like
why did you do that it's insane like
this isn't what you get out of that it's
like kill your teammates yeah you can so
it's got this system where you can shoot
someone you kill someone or they kill
you then you get a message saying do you
think that was on purpose
respect yes
and then that person gets like your
warning and if they do it again they get
kicked or banned
okay so uh maybe you've updated PC
sooner but lat and I haven't played PC
in a while but last time on PC it was
the first team kill is free like if you
team kills someone
nothing will happen it'll just warn you
if you do it again it'll redirect and
kill you no that's not really yeah on PC
be well actually they may have changed
its I haven't played in a couple weeks
but they did that because there would be
games where people were just team kill
because someone would say something in
chat that we make someone angry but
that's a really interesting yeah device
to put in a game yeah Wow am i taken
aback by that I don't know if it works
yet it's funny but I don't know if it
works yeah yeah because like people can
figure out ways to game unlike the
annoying thing is sometimes you do
accidentally shoot someone yeah like if
you did it if you like the kind of
person where like you kill someone else
yeah and then next time you're just
playing the game and someone walks in
front of you that's like I mean that
goes into the question I guess that Jake
was talking about that it prompts you
mm-hmm yeah but like that game is I
really like that game I want to get
better and deeper into it so I need to
get a good like setup going yeah that's
like sorry I'm still fixated on this
like when you try to shoot someone you
kill yourself it's like divine justice
yeah team killing is something they've
been trying to figure out since the game
launched cuz originally it was just you
just get you did get kicked if you do it
too many times
then they got stricter and then I think
they got a loser and now they're just
trying to do weird things to combat it
because I think if you got rid of team
killing in that game it would be an
issue because like it's all about sight
lines right yeah yeah and if your
teammates in the way that that's
supposed to happen like that they're
gonna mess you up you gotta coordinate
the other wall thing is like that rook
like pack of plates that you can shoe
that I put it down so like I play and
Kali plays this character as well rook
so he's his abilities like he'll put
down his bag and it's just full of like
armor plates that your teammates can
come and grab so I did that and then one
of my teammates rolled up and you shot
it and exploded I was like
how is that possible that's designed to
stop bullets and then like I was like
why the rules in this because like
everyone's trying to get this diffuser
kit why can't we just shoot the diffuser
kids and no one can get it it's mad it's
the same game it's it's good especially
especially playing with Matt he just
yells a lot does he oh yeah about just
he tries to play characters in the whole
place yeah he roleplay he's terribly he
is bad it's like he either talks about
or here are the role plays characters or
he talks about characters in the game
beating him up it's one of the two I did
my first friendly Pokemon sword and
shield tournament over the break so some
friends organized a monotype tournament
which is when you are assigned like a
particular type and you can only have a
team made of Pokemon er that are that
type and they can have two types but one
of them has to be the type you were
signed I got assigned randomly Electric
which I was not thrilled about that is
no this is really bad defensive typing
you could just totally be decimated by
one earthquake so I was kind of nervous
but I was allowed multiple Rotom forms
which is one Pokemon that has multiple
forms and that was just because the
organizer was like oh electric actually
doesn't have that many Pokemon in this
pokédex and so I got eliminated by Jake
in the first year al Jake with ghost
I had okay yeah head poison but I had
Gengar Cassie's ghost and poison yeah so
Jake eliminated me in the first round
and then I came back through the losers
bracket to get second place my team I
had wash Rotom so it's a washing machine
I had Drake wasn't one of the four the
fossil Pokemon it its front half is a
bird and its back half is a boy
[Laughter]
okay a washing machine uh that one was
actually one of my my best picks I was
really really happy with with him
I had talks tricity which was also on
Jake's team because it's poison electric
great system yeah and then uh what did I
oh Lt on everybody knows him and what
what Oh g'day Maru who's my secret
weapon I was really excited yeah it was
it was really a testament to I think the
the quality of life changes in the sword
and shield that I was able to get that
team I got a full team of six Pokemon
bred and trained and ready to go in less
than a week which is just like I never
could have done that before I was so
excited to actually have this Pokemon
and I can take those Pokemon and use
them on other teams so there's a lot of
fun and I definitely learned some things
do you came second yeah and I definitely
had the means to like if I had been
thinking I could have taken the last
battle but I totally was so flustered so
a really good battle practice what team
type today dark so he had an obstacle
which is the one that looks like gene
Simmons yep and it has this the set he
was using its abilities called guts and
it increases his attack by 50% and it
has a status condition like burn or
poison and it was holding an item a
flame orb which burns you after the
first turn so what I could have done is
on my Rotom my oven Rotom he wrote him I
had a move called trick which swaps your
item with the opponent's item and I
could have swapped I had a choice scarf
which locks you into one move so I could
have totally screwed over the obstacle
but instead I panicked and I just used a
move to try to damage him and then and
then he destroyed me he with that Austin
like killed me because its attack had
boosted by the Bernardin of the turn so
I learned a lot from that I was like oh
this is actually a very effective
counter to this strategy is the the
Rotom that I had made so it was really
fun and I spent I hid our 200 in Pokemon
she thank you yeah most of it was I was
hunting for a shiny Eevee and I'm gonna
turn into my um Brown cuz that's my
favorite Pokemon and I wanted a shiny
one to show how much I loved it
I got a shiny female which is incredibly
rare because only 25% of v's are female
so to get that was really good it
doesn't have its hidden ability that
would have been like the Trinity of rare
if I it had had two hidden abilities so
that was really fun next time yeah as I
did that and then I also played a lot of
modern warfare with my dad and my
brother they were really excited they
wanted to play with me so badly they
were like do you want to play spec ops
and I was like do I want to play spec
ops
well I love you so I guess I'll place oh
wow yes because it's wildly imbalanced
right yeah I do I do not like that mode
and this only solidified that that mode
is my brother so my brother is so good
at video games like so good at shooters
like stupidly good so he just carried us
through everything but he says user name
a while back again enos pounder thank
you and now it is orgasm oh I love my
brother so much and my dad was really
excited because my dad's always like
your brother was playing video games at
the same time as your dad using the
username anus pounder well my dad knew
that his name was anus pounder but he
got reported on xbox and had to change
it but it was so funny setting up like
cross-play because my brother plays on
PC that also helped us significantly my
dad's on xbox and I'm on ps4 so my dad
being like he's really into like new
technology was like super excited to try
cross play like he thought that was
really cool and so I had to be like to
my brother like okay give dad your
username and then like the numbers and
he was like it's Orgazmo and we were
like how do you spell that my dad had to
type in orgasm oh and I was like I have
a normal name here's mine but we played
and then we got tired of spec ups and we
played some multiplayer and there's a
shocking I tweeted about this a shocking
number of people and maybe it's not
shocking but a ridiculous number of
Magha and Trump related clan tags yeah I
played one match of multiplayer and the
first clan life is [ __ ] cow it was
straight up on mega clan I was like yeah
there's a lot of Magha I'm not a lot of
yeah I wonder if it's trolling but
there's got to be I imagine because on
on Call of Duty you can change your clan
any second I changed mine probably
twelve times over the break was playing
- like Defoe and stuff like so I I'm
sure a lot of people are just trying to
be funny and just trolling again what's
that there's none so make Atari games
again yes the new Canon kit can you
explain how that breaks it down to the
acronym
yeah whatever word Mecca oh that is four
words excuse me wait make at our great
we go dumb for but make Atari games
again Wow we all just that did not work
on ice we can't spell that's not even
spelling thinking abstract thinking yeah
sorry I played a lot of modern warfare
with Matt waiting to come in the pokemon
tournament Oh what last second the last
yeah but there was only four people it
wasn't like a there were many people but
I had a Poisson teams only four people
you still came in lost he didn't come
the second to last
because I won my first game which I
think was against me yeah yeah fourth
place at least okay kind of ganya I
placed you did place because there were
only four of us fun G first your last
though sweet
fine well anyway see you were feeling a
lot of Modern Warfare as well I'm not
with me because I was stuck playing with
orgasm oh yeah I played with with Matt
again and he changed his clan tag to
Obama I don't think that counter Nestle
works because he's not the president
anymore but whatever he did it anyway
and people still got mad at it so you
know did you play like the snowball mode
it was like a mode of gunfight which was
like the 2v2 mode but it was with
snowballs um I couldn't figure it out I
was so terrible and there's also yellow
snowballs yeah I didn't sometimes if you
did gunfight it would load you into like
a round of that for warmup and I that's
all I did it I didn't actually do it on
that I just played a lot of shipment
because they brought shipment back which
is from modern warfare 1 and it is a
disaster it is an absolute disaster like
there is I don't know how it's in this
game it is the most broken Call of Duty
map ever but it's still fun dad hey my
dad would not stop talking about how
much he hates [ __ ] man
what's his shipment like a mess back in
the day as well it probably was but I
think it's sort of more of a mess now
because like back in the day there were
three kill streaks right there is
there's your UAV your error airstrike
and helicopter now it's like we got a
chopper gunner rolling through a Harrier
strike there's four different counter
UAVs going off others and then
everyone's just hooking their grenades
and all their stupid gadgets and like
all you can do is just bunker down and
just camp
can we call your dad on speakerphone and
have him tell us what he thinks about so
bad shipment being pretty like not
broken but like insufferable back in the
day because like the mark between
martyrdom and lobbing grenades all right
yeah like that was enough to be like oh
man that's awful but yeah I can only
imagine what it's like in this day and
age where like the the kill streak
rewards are popping off every other
second and between like night vision and
Hey so we're recording our podcast right
now and we were wondering if you would
like to just give a state
on how shipment sucks
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna put you on speakerphone
just one second
we're talking about modern warfare and
and you hate shipment and we just want
it on record why why do you want
anything else you know you could just
spawn with you know I pulled the trigger
and that you'd have equal chance of
killing somebody is if you actually
played the game that's fair that sounds
bad yeah it's bad what is your favorite
quality your map of all time nice it's
pretty good thank you for being a
special guest on our podcast today dad I
love you I'm sorry to bother you wasting
your time but yeah I played a lot of
modern warfare I think it's one of my
it's I don't know I've played this Call
of Duty more than I have probably the
last five call of duty's combined if
that's there's anything and so I've been
enjoying and they did actually add crash
to it which is interesting because they
added like some really great modern
warfare 1 maps to it and then they had a
shipment too cuz they're like ah [ __ ] it
let's just put it in there see I forgot
the name of it what's the one that's
like in the fake like block of suburbian
though like the Soviet bloc no no it's
just like Oh new town new town it's like
two houses all because in New Town back
here no cuz that's a Treyarch they put
that other trailer whatever please meet
my friend Treyarch but yeah that usually
shows up in like the black ops like that
shame I still got that turf war going on
between I would have been like let's
just put all of them in together now at
this point yeah that's a shame
well anyway you and I both played some
attempt em - oh yeah template mmm alpha
that was interesting I'm so first of all
the music is just Pokemon music it's
personal slightly remixed but it does
have some ideas I did want to talk about
this cuz it has some ideas that I think
Pokemon could really like
should take note so they could steal it
and one of those was if you're playing
either by yourself or with a friend like
if you're playing with a friend so Jake
and I have been like grouped up I'll
send out one tempt him and he'll send
out the other
another Tim Tim and we'll have like it's
like a double battle in Pokemon I keep
wanting to call them Pokemon by the way
it's really hard to call them time time
but it there's like certain moves that
are more effective if you have if your
partner is like a certain type and it's
really really cool it's just like a
clever way to encourage like fire yeah
like yeah the way you would line up on
the field yeah and I just think it's
really clever there's nothing quite like
that like obviously Pokemon has double
battles that's how the competitive scene
is played and having like some synergy
on the field is important and there's
moves that can affect like there's a
move helping hand which like increases
the power of your partner's move but
there's nothing like this where like the
move is increased in power because of
the type that your partner is and I
think that's really interesting it is
also really cool to battle alongside
somebody that's something that people
been asking for in Pokemon forever so if
not necessarily add the MMO aspect of it
that I find attractive it's like oh we
can coordinate it'll be like oh let's
double up on the guy on the left and and
stuff like that yeah personally the MMO
stuff I don't at least so far it's still
office they might add things but I don't
really know why it's an MMO other than
the fact that like okay cool I guess
there are other people following the
same exact path I am through this kind
of linear world so it's just like I
don't really know why but the coop is
pretty cool how you can just add someone
quickly to your to your game and then
all of a sudden you're adventuring
together and stuff like that like that
that was pretty seamless I expected oh
yeah it being an Alf I expected like a
lot of Hoops we'd have to jump through
it wouldn't work or we'd have to be at
the same stage and again it just we
loaded right in I had to put replay some
of it but you know is it was pretty neat
dude and like we teamed up or partnered
up like right after I started so Jake
was ahead of me I went through like the
introduction sequence and it's very like
much of this game is just be exactly
like Pokemon like
you get you pick from one of three
monsters and you get what a crystal type
a rolling melee type and a mental type
mental type which was a little different
but yes you do that and then like I like
I'm smashing through the cutscene and
then I joined up with Jake and so I get
I think the problem with playing with
somebody else is that you're not really
incentivized to explore or talk to
characters because maybe this is like a
thing and I've never played an MMO
before so I don't know how that works in
like final fantasy xiv but i was like i
don't want to bore jake with like me
reading like we should go do things so
but it's interesting it's definitely a
work in progress there's like buildings
that say like WIP on the side and like
you can't go in but it's like supposed
to be something and it's hard it's like
they were like Pokemon is way too easy
let's kick some asses it's also not
balanced yet did you say single-player
Pokemon is too easy in general I would
say yeah Pokemon is is I was I don't
think so I was talking to you about this
like it's been a while since I like try
to play a like deep into a Pokemon
single-player experience but
like I think it's a good game I'm glad
people really love it but like the
single-player experience for me it feels
really thin like I was asking Jake like
when do I get like the equivalent of a
Silph scope and have to go through a
towering yeah running from like town to
town to town to town to town like for
badges and I'm just like rolling through
all these I got fought like one Gym
Leader and it was like I had a Pikachu
and I can remember like it was a it was
like the I don't think it was a peak to
you it was like an elemental type that I
shouldn't been able to be I was just
like it Giganta max and I was like well
I'm just gonna ignore everything that
you've just done and see if I can just
roll through you I think it was a
Pikachu I just destroyed the Giganta max
version of this Pokemon with my tiny
Pokemon and I was like I was not
challenging and it's just like run to
the next town and it's not like caves or
towers or anything like to go like that
so I was very surprised like I didn't
know that stuff had been like removed
from the game well that was kind of one
of the interesting interesting things
about let's go is that it brought that
world back from generation one so it did
have a lot of the stuff that newer games
are missing like yeah like rock tunnel
for instance is like a maze that takes a
while to get through and then the Silph
scope and stuff like that like there are
dungeons more or less in that game which
they didn't have in the last one really
and and Sun and Moon so it was weird to
play let's go Chad that again and then
back to sword and shield which was kind
of just like go to point A to point B
and just until you yeah I was very
surprised by that it's interesting to
hear you say that just cuz that's
totally like not something I thought
about playing through the campaign just
cause like I'm just enjoying it as like
my fun Pokemon adventure and then I'm
like and now I get to like psycho
territory or like I play for another 150
hours it like so I'm not like looking
for that but obviously most people who
play I don't know maybe he's like that
but I asked my younger brother and he
didn't seem to like be able to tell me
like there's no like fee Matic points
where like oh I'm in the ghost town now
now I need to go through there like
because where I got my gas T and and
Haunter and Gengar from was that tower
that you know that haunted Tower
sounds like where's the Hornet tower
equivalent in this game so I can get my
Ganga or my
on my home tour golf day and I can
evolve and he was like yeah there is
there's nothing I was like what's yeah
I've kind of forgotten that that was a
yeah the reason you guys are we're all
talking about it like I fell in love
with the original case yes that's why I
really really like I that's why I got
excited about getting ready for and then
like I was three badges you know I was
like I don't what's missing here and
then I realized it was like a story
jumping on a bike and just bathing to
the next point and and then I like
destroy that town's gym leader and then
two rivals come up and they're like hey
I'm gonna kick your ass sounds like I
totally agree like a I think
there's plenty to enjoy outside of that
like I think the wild area is super
strong exploring the wild area is such a
strong incentive I haven't done much of
that so yeah that's like I think that's
what helps mitigate the the feeling of
the rest of that missing the wild air
you're really is really just like
something I think it's really and there
are some good challenges too in the wild
area especially the early on well early
on they're very easy but then when you
get the raids like something through the
game and you're getting like three or
four star raids and you have are four or
five star raids and you've got like
level 50 Pokemon then it's like alright
there's gonna be really tough really you
need like for human people to take down
a Snorlax yeah I guess like I like the
battling element of it but I feel like I
need like there's the puzzle solving
element or like the experts because
actors that that's that one team rocket
tower where you're pulling switches to
try and get ice that you're slaying and
like doing that alongside battling you
know team rocket goons or whoever air
rival trainers like that's what was the
texture for me alongside the battles
because like I don't play competitively
and I'd I don't even like I won't
pretend to understand like the
intricacies of compare Pokemon in the
same way that you do or you do so like
without that element of it the game just
feels very thin to me like I roll up and
I'm like oh is there's a water pokemon
electric shock that until it's dead and
then I move on like I'm not and there's
no nuance to my style whatsoever I'm
just using the most powerful move I have
over and over again until it's dead so
like it feels like mechanically like a
regression you gotta you gotta do the
wild area I think you'll enjoy that
that's why I dig into it does that have
like themed areas where it's like yeah
even a ghost tower you can't go in it
but there is a thick Tower but I've
never it's never activated I think it's
something little be activated later
mm-hmm maybe tomorrow oh yeah we can
that's a great segue if we want to talk
about smooth yeah well I mean tomorrow
there's going to be Pokemon direct
however if you're listening this on
Friday or watching this on Friday it's
already happened so we figured I don't
believe they opened the ghost
Wow we figured the way to do this would
be Callie and I and you guys we can try
to predict what we're gonna see tomorrow
and you guys can tell us how wrong we
are you can have fun listening to how
wrong we are actually I'm usually
extremely right about Pokemon for yeah
so we just do what your prediction
because I have no idea what I'm even
gonna other than like some obvious stuff
so my prediction this is actually my
like official 2020 prediction for
GameSpot as well was that they're going
to continue to support Pokemon sword and
shield with like DLC content including I
believe that they're going to add more
Pokemon to the game like that is so in
addition to the 30 some Pokemon that
work data mined a 34 is what I saw
before podcast I was doing some research
homework there Pokemon that were data
mined and like they're able to be in the
game but aren't in the game so that
includes like Bulbasaur and squirtle
because why just Charmander yeah
so in sin Aurora why don't they have
gangly tsk well yeah it's insane to me
that they don't have I know right put
the glasses on the squirrel so I think
they're going to in addition to those
Pokemon being brought to the game when
Pokemon home comes out I think there's
going to be more Pokemon adds to the
game as part of kind of a roll out part
of the reason I think that is because
there are unused raid dens in the wild
area that don't like do anything or like
don't have like special as far as I know
according to Joe Marik from Sarah B so
that's like my big prediction is that
they're gonna announce like upcoming
content first sword and shield and then
I also think that we're gonna hear more
about Pokemon home I would really be
surprised if we didn't I'd actually be
concerned if we didn't hear anything
about Pokemon home because I think a lot
of people are looking forward to that
surface people like bringing their all
Pokemon forward and seeing them in unity
college get married yes see them grow up
you know so
do you think it'll just be a hub where
you transfer your Pokemon - do you think
they'll be like minigames when they
announced it so yeah I mean I hope so
especially because there are undoubtedly
Pokemon that aren't going to be
transferable to sword and shield so it's
like what do you do with them besides
put them in the cloud I don't know I
hope you can use them again once go
pokemon heaven they went to the Pokemon
farm what about detective Pikachu - and
Pokemon sleep damn it yeah but like his
DLC for shield like you know like you
can kept on no no but like he would show
up it's like introduced like a plot line
there were the other Pokemon I want to
join his like effort so you'd have like
detective garbodor or whatever you like
pick the worst Pokemon to become
detectives and have them detective
garbodor and I was so proud of you for
saying it correctly you could use every
point guard builder it's a murder and
every point during a high-profile murder
the cops eventually seek a psychic you
find a Ganga and try and converse with
the dead Pokemon the Gengar just licks
everyone's face and moves on with it's
like the the single place I want as well
so go on bring detective Pikachu to that
game my prediction is that it's going to
be a 20 minute long threat from the
Pokemon company to the 10/10 developers
beans like stop it this is not this is
never gonna be on switch Jake will you
say Pokemon sleep well I mean do you
think they'll talk about Pokemon sleep
probably maybe maybe do we know anything
about that
alright it tracks your sleep and gives
you rewards in Pokemon go Pokemon dreams
I'm already there it's my whole life I
mean I'm gonna reach for the stars I
don't think this is gonna happen
but maybe they'll announce a remake of
one of the older ones which one would
you want crystal crystal crystal I don't
think it'll happen because too soon it's
too soon but it also is a 20 minute
presentation which I feel like it's
pretty long for Pokemon it is it's
actually the longest presentation that
they've had a Pokemon game I know this
from so Joe Merrick did a thread about
this Joe Merrick is the founder and site
runner of sarahfey he has listed the
lengths of previous Pokemon directs and
this one is the longest by far so
they've been anywhere from so well
actually September 4th 2013 was 19
minutes and 25 seconds I think that
might have been was that the like 20 no
it wouldn't have been that's not a
twentieth but I bet they were like 20
minute Pokemon direction coming in a
couple of days then so there's probably
19 minutes this is the longest one the
time between the release of a game in
reveal of the next one he also lists out
so this is interesting information from
black and white to the announcement of
black and white to 17 months from black
and white to 2x and wise announcement 7
from XY to orous seven months from
orestes Sun and Moon 15 months from Sun
and Moon to ultra Sun the ultramarine
seven months and then from ultrasound an
ultramarine to let's go six months let's
go to sword and shield was three months
but this wouldn't even be to from
release to the announcement of a new
game so we would be the shortest time
between the release of a game and the
announcement of a new one Peter what's
up no I'm just following along oh you
were I thought you were like shaking
your head like that can't be right just
say new Pokemon information say could be
like 5 minutes 10 minutes of Pokemon go
updates right or maybe it's just you
sleeping I don't know if they've done
Pokemon go information much in the
Pokemon nicely for thee I I bet it'll be
a lot of detective Pikachu too because
if they announced that a while ago now
and that's probably gonna be the next
big Pokemon game I imagine is this
pokemon this year I don't know but I
imagine is probably coming out that's
probably there
the biggest Pokemon game coming soon
yeah so part of my prediction for the
support a sword and shield was that
there wouldn't be another new Pokemon
game this year so I'm sticking to those
guns we're not gonna hear anything about
that because I think that this is gonna
be like the closest Game Freak has
gotten two games of service like let's
keep updating this game so you think
there won't be any Pokemon game this
year so like does I figured you count
like cuz it's kind of like a spin-off so
the detective Pikachu's developed by
creatures it's a different developer so
that is that can't exist outside totally
but I wonder if maybe that wouldn't be
in a Pokemon direct because it's not
Game Freak but Ishihara would be
delivering the direct so but that would
be why I wouldn't expect Pokemon sleep
is because the Pokemon sleep in Pokemon
home announcement was part of a weird
look it was a Japanese press conference
specifically that's the same kind of
press conference that I actually
attended for the let's go announcement
so I wonder if they're moving towards
announcements in that venue it's very
unpredictable for some of those what
they announce a Pokemon for smash in a
Pokemon direct or a smash through a
smash yeah also I think obstacle be
perfect for smash that actually be a
good one yeah I'm sure come on but one
thing to consider maybe is is that when
Pokemon home comes out you're able to
transfer Pokemon from red blue gold
silver all the DS and 3ds games right
are all the 3ds games and yes transfer
you are currently able to transfer
Pokemon from your Gameboy Advance games
so Ruby and Sapphire up through to
Pokemon Bank Pokemon home the only games
where your Pokemon our locked would be
the original Gameboy okay once but
because those are Virtual Console games
on 3ds you could transfer Pokemon from
those games but they wouldn't be your
originals or anything and they'd have
randomized stats and stuff well what if
they bring some of those games like red
and blue and gold and silver to switch
Oh that'd be so cool so they never
figured out a way to transfer say
through like pokemon stadium to bring
gameboy to those book1 are locked on
there
rest in peace those Pokemon arrested
peace tears knowing you those I mean
those batteries are dead now so well
anyway this has been quite the Pokemon
episode but we got to move on here a big
thing that happened this week was the PS
5 logo was shown off and what a piece of
graphic design it is yeah I mean I don't
think anyone saw this coming right I
don't really get why people are people
are mad because people want things to be
very different they want to feel
surprised to just see this Sony been
like well I'm glad I didn't judge
because honestly we had the spider-man
fund that was horrible yeah that played
almost a generation of so we've got all
this built up like recognizability in
this logo which week is boring I mean
this random dude on the Internet is
gonna be real upset they don't care
about what you think I've seen some
people take the ps2 logo and turned that
into the PS 5 logo because the - yeah
yeah that I think is more aesthetically
pleasing and I think given mm given
because ps2 is the best-selling console
of all time
mm-hmm I could see argument for kind of
going back to that just for a nostalgia
play just to people who are they I bet
you they will do a version of the PS 5
with the ps2 low that's like a ps2
Universal yes they had like a yes yes
yeah yeah so I bet you for the ps2 or
the PS 5 they'll have a ps2 version of
it I hope you're right goddamn it
yeah I'm right my friend mr. play
station texted me about it I was like
this is happening here's a funny name no
we're gonna go with like Sammy Sony no
way crappy education I've told you about
my friend John Paul Qualcomm
I don't knows anything else bring up
about the ps5 look they didn't really
say anything about it right like gaming
posts on Instagram ever what yes yes
five logos crazy popular on Instagram
for and nobody knows why it's so stupid
I love that Jim Ryun took the stage like
ahead like everyone's like right
Microsoft have just shown off the new
Xbox was Jim rancor he's like JPEGs JPEG
a real big dudes he's like but I mean
didn't they also announced that the ps4
sold 105 million yeah a ton of units so
literally whatever we want it makes it
number two behind PlayStation 2 how many
did done for committing us not that's
it's more money than I have that's
absolutely smaller units than I have for
units and more money that I have
absolutely another thing to come on a
CES was the Alienware UFO right or if
the alien or switch I it's too angular
it would hurt my hands that's all I have
to say it's also probably not going to
be successful no we've we've seen we've
seen companies try to do this before III
don't see any point to this device
existing other than to just get people
hype off of the fact that it's similar
to switch early adopters will buy it and
then it'll die a slow death because
Dells not gonna commit to it they can't
sell specialized hardware like this in
the PC space and expect to be super
successful it's never worked look at
Alienware sorry steam steam machines
right garbage right they were chasing a
trend trying to turn PC gaming into
something it's not
it doesn't work
have that Alienware very nicely hold
that this was stated yeah I mean I
watched we have a video I think it's up
by now it should be up by now
about it we're matt Padgett and my
something called the UFO yeah yeah what
about it I was like you're leaning too
hot into the alien thing look it's a
it's a you know they're calling it a
prototype they don't have a price for
this that thing is a working piece of
hardware there's nothing stopping them
all they're doing is market research
right now to see if this thing is even
viable they found out that there's
marketing hype to be had behind it
because people are like oh it's like
switch but listening to our impressions
of it listening to the the way that the
people at the booth are interacting with
Matt and and Michael it just sounds like
they're there this is just a free sort
of market test for them put it out there
called a prototype makes zero promises
other than hey it kind of looks like
switch right that's about all they have
to offer
720p gameplay of 30 frames per second
like why would you considering this
thing is gonna cost way more than $300
Yeah right it has to based on the
quantity they're gonna be able to sell
it right Nintendo makes millions of
consoles they can obviously bring
manufacturing costs down
Dehlia where they're not gonna sell
millions of these things they're gonna
cost a lot per unit for what benefit the
idea of playing PC games on the go not
the actual experience maybe things will
change in five to ten years but right
now no there's no place for that thing
now five ten years you just be playing
all those games on your phone you won't
need one I just I'll be put you in my
mind in my ear and then also like in
Futurama when I get the iPhone installed
in there I exactly only Lucy was here
and then the other big thing is Final
Fantasy 7 pretty much got leaked in its
entirety when you say that what do you
mean cuz I'd miss this like everything
so well so the the demo leaked and they
don't mind the demo and they found
references to things that are to come
so things that will if I'm remembering
this correctly I didn't look too into it
because I don't want to be spoiled
completely but the idea being that there
are things that are not within the
section of the game that we know is
going to encompass
the first episode and there are things
referenced that could appear within that
episode which have not before so it's a
sort of thing where it's like oh there
might be some changes we're not
expecting what is there stuff like the
lost boss of the game is in there well
but apparently I've been trying to avoid
as well but like there's that and like I
haven't heard that I would be shocked if
they're planning that now when the first
episode covers I didn't want to say 1/10
less than normally lost once for the
first episode oh yeah when you said the
game I was expecting like yeah I'm
talking about the upcoming soundtrack is
out there as well now turn your back a
little bit episode 1 covers about or
Part 1 covers about a tenth of in my if
you played the original so yeah it only
takes place in Midgar Midgar is you know
you think of Final Fantasy games as they
were a huge world map exploit like this
ends before you get to the world map ok
so now it's really depending on how you
play the original you can get like you
know five to eight hours if you really
want to maximize every possibility
within that environment and they're
adding stuff to it for this they're also
streamlining the game and you know
whatever but yeah it's a it's a very
small chunk of the experience because
well I mean I don't know we don't know
how much of Final Fantasy seven they're
going to bring into the future episodes
there's a lot of stuff that is super
optional which if you talk to someone
like me who put everything into that
game those optional things mean a lot
but they might not see that being worth
development for a game that's really now
focused on mainstream before Final
Fantasy 7 was like we're selling this on
the visuals alone we'll have so for RPG
fans but now they're selling it more for
modern audience anyway first episode is
yeah it's going to be just one session
ok one very early section how are you
feeling about it I'm very excited I I'm
not worried about like the legacy of the
game being disrespected or like I'll
always have the original game I've
played the demo at least the one that
they had at e3 and I loved the gameplay
changes they made I got a hint of
character and narrative changes that I'm
interested in seeing more of
and I'm as interested to be displeased
by what I see as I am to be happy with
what they've done
like I think re-examining why we like
games and why we attach ourselves to
them as part of identity is really
important and for me seven is one of
those games and so I'm really curious to
see what a lot of the original creators
really think about it and what they're
gonna do with it now 13 it's a 13 or is
it 23 23 years later yeah so I'm here
for it even if it's bad I really want to
see it the only thing I don't like so
far is Barrett's voice he sounds like
Robert Downey jr. in his tropic that's
too bad that's definitely a shame yeah
yeah
there is anything anyone's sad about
final fantasy 7 I'm excited for it yeah
yeah I'm excited I'm excited to play it
yeah I was anticipating game next year
huh I'm I know so little about Final
Fantasy I'm super counting on Peter to
for these for the review they're really
wondering everything right now is one of
the it's a it's really advantageous
excuse to dive into a game the way I
used to as a kid who's I can set aside
work for a couple days and really just
live in that game so what a game to do
it with more than anything
yeah that's attitude that I love so much
and I'm ready I'm ready to call it [ __ ]
too
you know I mean I'm high things are good
oh yeah most things are not good it's
nice to fall in love with things it's
nice to it's like fun to give positive
reviews but it's also fun to like really
examine why you don't like something and
that doesn't mean it's not but doesn't
mean it's fun to be mean no to figure
out why you don't like it the most
boring review to write is a six it's
what fans want good but there's
something for everyone yeah I don't like
writing sevens either like if I find I
find that I'm writing a review for games
like good I am not having fun yeah I can
already imagine anyone giving Final
Fantasy 7 a 7 and the comments just be
like you're just doing this yeah the the
fun part about writing reviews is when
you're playing the game you're like I
get to play a game like I used to and
then the not fun part is after you
publish and you're like time to wait i
watch the video back of our game of the
year discussion about Secura and it was
a comment on there someone that was like
I don't think this guy has played the
game
see when people say that about me I just
spoiled the game for them don't ever say
that to me I will spoil the game for you
anyway if you have any questions you can
write in it after dark podcast at
gamespot.com but we're gonna move right
into our listener questions Kelly do you
want to read the first one sure this one
is actually two questions hello to the
after-dark crew one so you guys like
gaming but what else do you guys enjoy
doing as much as gaming what are some of
your other hobbies in life does Jake
love to cook is Lucy the most avid stamp
collector what about Michael is he big
into knitting love that the audience
wants to know and then number two after
hearing you guys were couch shopping for
the set it got me thinking why do you
feel like a table with chairs isn't
enough for on cam it seemed to do the
job back on the old podcast hosted by
mr. v Nord
lastly discord access keep up the great
work guys I loved the podcast Hugo Roy I
bet his name is huge Roy first start
with our hobbies I guess I like big
butts and I can mean I spend probably
too much money on cameras and lenses and
I don't take enough photos or shoot
enough stuff with them but that is
something that I love to do I love
taking photos and that kind of stuff you
can add over like lenses and cameras and
that kind of stuff the the shitty thing
is that cameras are expensive lenses are
expensive so you know that that that
hobby like I can only really I guess
invest myself into that once a year so
and I've gotten right I got some money
saved up but I can still take photos
whenever I don't do it enough he is with
the most interesting no yeah yeah yeah
tell us about all the cool stuff that
you're into mine's a cool stuff tell us
like I collect and use old Sony like
monitors that were used in like
production and broadcast environment
and then I modify old consoles based on
technology developed by the incredibly
talented and generous retro gaming
community to improve the video output of
these old systems and play them on these
monitors that are way higher quality
than any CRT we all could have bought
like for our home so yeah I like to
tinker and get new things out of old
systems and justify trying to just hold
on desperately to my youth I also I'm
really into Katsuhiro Otomo the artists
behind akira and a lot of other things
and I like to collect things that he is
made and I have a cat it's pretty
alright it's great cat pretty good cat
yeah those are my hobbies I guess what
do I have outside of video games anime
is good unless so these days because
it's so hard to get in in San Francisco
yeah responsible yeah you vape
responsibly yeah yeah yeah studying
Japanese comic books
I'm really into hip-hop anybody help me
that's pretty much what we're talking
about earlier we talked about someone
being hip-hop I cannot remember that may
have been a Kurt conversation a
conversation you had with your best
friend Kurt yes who texted me during
this text that's my other hobby is yeah
maybe it's the most boring normal stuff
pretty much it um I also like studying
Japanese I so
I'm really into the idea of journaling
but I don't actually do it so like I
hate do you like a pair of drink you get
comfortable have your nose yeah like I
have I have all of the materials
necessary to maintain and bullet journal
but I don't but I'm really into like
nice lettering oh yeah oh yeah I like
nice calligraphy I enjoy Pride and
Prejudice in all its forms
true crime true crime yeah we love
learning about murders yeah forgot about
that well you watch Gregory on Netflix
no I still need to watch the cat one oh
the cat [ __ ] with cats is real good but
there's a sec it's did you know what
don't poke at says I've only seen like
the the thumbnail for it I don't know so
like this it's about this guy who
suddenly appears on the internet and
started posting videos of cats being
killed yeah and then it follows like the
International hunt from for him as he
escalates to killing people I don't
think at all
oh so the tricky thing is like it's all
it's partly about like initially this
person was found and like became or
alerted or gone and the attention of a
Facebook group almost like a vigilante
Facebook group and it was like
circulation of you know horrible
Internet videos that they kind of found
him via and the videos are other cat
being killed various different cats
being killed and it's and they don't
show it oh they do the thing where they
show the setup of the cat like cat being
placed somewhere
and then it cuts to someone describing
someone from the vigilante group
describing it but like it's horrendous
stuff and I watched it and I like as it
was happening I looked at my cat was in
the room I was like I've got for this
bit so like I you can easily very like
skip forward a couple of times
and you won't miss it all you need to
know is a cat was killed in a horrible
way
and usually people will discuss one of
that yeah it's rough but like it's worth
skipping through that just to see where
it goes off it's so weird like
I can watch the rest of the the
documentary where it's like and then he
killed a human being without a problem
but like the cat pom like Oh Lord no
which is like a damning indictment on
like why why am I like this to date the
most upsetting a crime documentary I
watched was one where nobody died it's a
the abducted in plain sight
yeah that one is so messed up and nobody
died and I was really upset and then I
watch all these I watched like the Ted
Bundy tapes and I was bored yeah yeah
yeah but it's worth watching because
that that story goes some places he's
like holy moly how did that happen it's
like three episodes and they're about an
hour each and I watched him like one off
the other and it was like I couldn't
stop watching it was genuinely like
fascinating and gripping stuff and like
is a fairly recent story as well so
that's another thing like a lot of the
true-crime stuff that happens it's like
Oh back in the day you know there was
this one killer yeah yeah now it's like
I'm not this person's like a modern era
serial killer and it's it's messed up
and I was so fascinating and also it's a
lot about like vigilantism and in the
most ham-fisted way it also becomes
about the consumption of true crime as a
hobby
it's not done with any nuance at all but
it does make a statement about it and
when it made it I was like shut up but
it's it's worth watching
yeah yeah I also really like interior
design which brings us to Hugo's second
question which was about by the guy the
couch um well I think we're kind of
tired of using the giant bomb space they
need that a lot too so they smell and
they smell yeah so that was a big we're
gonna move to that and we kind of bounce
back and forth between couch chairs but
we ended up with this with this nice
couch right here that the CBS orange the
CBS Orange honestly I don't really
really know why we ended up with a couch
over a table I did like a table we had a
table for a bit when we were doing the
lobby it was nice
yes I know that was Peters face yes and
still is god damn it I think is just
because it's a little trickier to shoot
that way so I don't know if you also
remember when we did do that Andy was
roaming was Andy and then I think
Richard was doing roaming camera for it
it felt like a more natural conversation
sort of thing because I think I don't
know yeah it just for me it worked
better well the audience can tell us how
this one's way yeah we only have one
person who's doing camera things so
there's less labor-intensive those who
plan on adding more artwork and stuff
like that yes this is a little bare
right now Oh get there yeah it's a work
in progress just like a lot of those
buildings and temp tempered access but
you gave an update on disk right access
the beginning of the show so should we
do the I want two more to read the news
Roy yeah I think tomorrow
hi old loving the pod so far now listen
to all the episodes and I'm loving the
chill hype vibes which i think is the
official genre for our podcast sure
vibes like we should get that in are
actually like podcast art like games
fall off the dock in like curses
it's so perfect I may look chill I'm so
high for a second we got that email two
more turned in he's like did you see
this chill pipe on point
he's perfect like we should have that as
a mission statement only show hype vibes
in this post so for a while my bold
prediction for the future of Xbox was
that the next Xbox would just be a
gaming PC now that could could we be
good there could there be a wall where
that um I was a typo it wasn't me just
unable to read the word there could
there be a world where that still
happens what if the Xbox ear is X s Z
xxx
whatever ran windows OS under the hood
imagine a world where Xbox ports are
just windows bills of the of games and
Xbox is like this pcs with a console
like UI I mean look at it I think that
was supposed to be a picture there was
loading and I didn't copy but it's just
a picture the Xbox one X so imagine it
okay okay it's a picture of the Xbox
here's a picture in your mind that the
moment to really picture it like really
like Joshua lies yes exactly yeah that
thing thinks it's a PC referring to the
Xbox Series X I could imagine Microsoft
announcing this alongside an updated OS
it also feels like you're fits really
well into their service base play
anywhere philosophy
I'll keep sitting here dreaming about
playing AoE for on my xbox with a mouse
someday soon thanks I appreciate you Joe
in Seattle oh I like that
appreciate you that's really sweet I
mean
I was a lot but the question I guess is
could they just make a PC Xbox I mean
that kind of goes to what Peter was
saying earlier about specialized PC
hardware hmm I feel like there has to be
enough to differentiate a console yeah
and and what that is is dedication and
that's what consoles are right they're
dedicated pieces of gaming hardware that
are I think if you broke it down until
like the raw terms it is a PC especially
now more than ever because it's based on
the same I know
familiar x86 x64 architecture that
Windows is based on and it likely does
have Windows components under the hood
like DirectX is something that's very
closely associated with Windows but
Windows is more than just the graphical
user interface you use it's the
underlying code and that could very well
be present within the Xbox series X and
you'd never know it doesn't mean it's
not necessarily there I think it
behooves Microsoft to have a business
where they were making something that's
different than a standard PC because
Microsoft can't as that as the way they
are as a company they don't sell pcs
they sell gaming consoles they sell
tablets they sell operating systems they
sell office software and cloud solutions
they're not a PC manufacturer and they
can't compete in that space necessarily
if they did they would be losing the
edge by having to build it an operating
system that works with this very gaming
specialized hardware and all the user
needs that could come from offering such
a broad product I think the solution
that you're looking for is something
like a device that streams your PC
signal to your TV and using a wireless
mouse and keyboard to play those games
yeah that's something you can do today
the investments not very high and if you
want to be a PC gamer now is easier than
ever to make that happen on your TV so I
think the Xbox will probably forever
continue to be what it is which is a
specialized gaming device and not be
confused with the PC yep sorry it's a
premature that's that's why I put this
question because I was like I you know
what I bet I bet he's gonna grant
appeals gonna nail this one yeah I I
like this question because it's for all
of us including Jay especially Jake
a weeb question for you all today what
are your favorite Studio Ghibli movies
are just favorite anime movies overall I
really love Howl's Moving Castle the boy
and the piece in your name thanks for
reading hope you all had a wonderful
break Caleb he can take it away
Jake you back to me I really like a
silent voice if we want to talk like
recent anime movies I was talking to
Kurt about this because Kurds from a
town that has a lot are large like deaf
and hard of hearing population so he
speaks or he knows American Sign
Language and it's taught us a lot of
dirty things but a silent voice is about
it's kind of hard to watch because in
the first like 20 minutes are just
watching a class of 10 year-olds bully a
deaf girl relentlessly but the movie is
about one of the bullies like coming to
terms with what he did to her and
growing from that experience and I think
it's really beautiful it came out the
same year as your name in the US and I
liked it a lot more than your name
actually and of shin Kai's work I would
say I like five seven years per second
more than your name I'm gonna see
weathering with you which is his new one
next week but yeah I really loved a
silent voice I think it got overlooked
in favor of your name and I I think it's
really excellent yes oh yeah oh and
summer Wars I really like summer wars
summer wars and the girl who left
through time
I think the girl who left free time I
really like my favorite Ghibli movies
probably or cheaply movie depending how
you say is probably Kiki's Delivery
Service I have two cats named Kiki so
can you can you explain everybody how
your cats names work because together
they collectively are Kiki right Oh Kiki
Kiki son who's the older a mother of
Kiki champ so we just called them Kiki
and they both respond and they come and
so it's like I said I'm gonna give you
different names you both
you know March the same name so we just
called him Kiki signing Kiki channel oh
yeah
not named after the cat in the movie
though rash is weird but it was just the
movie that I was watching when we caught
the cat it was like well you're gonna be
called Kiki now but obviously my
neighbor totoro was great and all the
other movies Princess Mononoke yeah for
a lot of reasons I don't necessarily
think they need to be described but I
will give a shout out to my neighbor's
the Yamada's which is a product of not
Miyazaki but Takagi sahaja I'm getting
his name correctly I hope he's sort of
one of the other creators like who also
worked on like grave of the fireflies
and stuff like that under the Ghibli
banner and my neighborhood your mottos
are bunch of shorts of like a family of
Japanese people like three generations
very slice of life very kind of loosely
illustrated with very comical heartfelt
scenes that just kind of work in our
very self-contained and it's easy to
just watch all of them forget I made
there are there are a ton well I've only
seen Princess Mononoke and spirit away
so I guess spirited away
I like ghost in the shell' - that's not
a studio people on the original movie or
stand alone complex or the original
movie yeah it's the only one I've seen
sorry I don't like I would a lot of
people gonna disagree with me but I
think that's the only one you kind of
have to see really I think so
I just double check the name of it is
also a movie called sort of stranger
which I love quite a lot Masahiro under
film animation by bones oh I can't
believe it and say Akira I thought you
were just leaving it out no you do yeah
I thought it was like obvious how do we
feel about Tokyo Godfather's you know
very very I love Satoshi killing stuff
it he it's I think anime would be so
different today if he was still alive
him and Shinkai like if they because
they would be the two leading the charge
in terms of anime cinema and they're
very very different in what they do but
Jake's pretending like he doesn't
and he does I'm just pretending I mean I
don't know you should watch Tokyo got
you should definitely watch perfect blue
I think you'd really like perfect blue
perfectly millennium actress is good
pretty much anything Satoshi Cohn is
ever done is just a masterpiece
apparently I was gonna say paranoia
agent I don't know like that one he
doesn't feel as essential yeah I'm like
I feel like I wouldn't with like paprika
no but perfect blue I mean as a film
there and I think perfect blue would
just you would fall in love at that
movie I'm really everything makes me
think of big blue which makes me think
of a big blue house no Captain Falcon
yeah Captain Falcon is that was is that
the song never mind I sound crazy we
were jamming two more planks max yes
isn't it called big blue I think that's
what it's called can you play that on
the outro don't that one maybe maybe
maybe you might I don't know anyway
that's been episode 23 of GameSpot after
dark I'm not sure which cameras supposed
to look at all of them it was a look at
the center one thank you all for tuning
in and remember if you have questions
please email us after dark podcast at
gamespot.com we read through all of your
questions and we pick a good amount of
them to read out on the show and answer
them so please send us please send those
to us because they're my favorite part
of the show
Callie where can people find you and
what are you working on I'm well I'm
getting back into the swing of things
after break but I'm still working on my
competitive pokémon like explainer I am
sure that I did some Pokemon content for
the direct but you can now read that's
what I sure hope happens tomorrow unless
something bad happens to me and you can
find me on twitter at indeed ojika i am
kygo ji kko yes I wish I could change it
and I'm sorry don't be sorry it's good
it's great tomorrow I'm on Twitter at
more H you can find me working on new
stuff we've also got loadout original
programming show that I helped out on
and a few episodes of that are out now I
think this week I don't want to say
which one it is in case I'm wrong but
there's a couple of episodes already out
around sniper rifles and the warhammer
weapon the bowler which is really cool
it's done Audio log season 2 which is
also another show they helped out on a
few episodes out now and the kijima one
is out the control one is out so if you
played control and you enjoy the ashtray
maze and you want to see how they made
that as an episode of all your logs all
about it and there'll be another episode
two days time from now Sunday the Sunday
after you hear this and that one's gonna
be amazing as well so check it out
subscribe leave some comments say you
know you guess that comes to me i'm on
twitter @pcc one
i don't tweet very much and good luck
finding my name on GameSpot because
everything I do these days is pretty
much behind the scenes Final Fantasy and
you can find me at jacob deck and I'm
working on a Witcher 3 video because you
know it's 2015 again I'm really leaning
into that brand hard
what do you how do you feel about the
toss a coin to your Witcher song so is
that it is that a Bop for you I didn't
really like it but people loved it if
people really I remember because we had
screeners and I will I watched it and I
think I was like messaging micro Joe
who's on the entertainment team and I
was like very like yeah that song kind
of sucks but people really liked it so
good for them
yeah alright and that's that on that
can that be our official sign-off and
that's and that's that on that we should
see you next week and that's that on
that we should do the Zapp Branigan
that's whatever you were talking about
for you
[Music]